preparing for a foreign invasion
Venezuela's president has ordered a show
of force for the rest of the continent
to see a hundred and fifty thousand
troops began wargames on Tuesday that
are expected to last for two weeks oh
yeah today has begun the deployment of
the entire army missile anti-aircraft
air defense comprehensive defense of the
entire territory of the 2219 kilometer
border with Colombia Venezuela and
Colombia have traded accusations of
harboring each other's enemies the US
says Maduro is openly supporting what it
calls narco terrorist groups which could
launch cross-border attacks on Colombian
forces I hope that the Armed Forces of
Venezuela will not allow Maduro to drive
them into some additional risks I hope
they're not crazy enough to engage in
any kind of attacks on Colombia and it's
certainly the case that Colombia will
have full American support if that
happens opposition leader Juan Guido
says the war games are an attempt to
divert attention from the political and
economic turmoil within Venezuela's
borders
i'ma Wando what we Venezuelans the
majority of Venezuelans are demanding is
to put an end to the suffering of our
people to deal with the complex
humanitarian emergency Venezuela is
grappling with acute shortages of food
and medicines the UN says one in five
are now suffering from hunger one and a
half million had fled the worsening
conditions to Colombia maderos critics
say he should spend more money on food
than missiles but he insists the drills
are needed to defend the homeland ander
Chappelle al-jazeera